welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Reema Salah an assistant clinical
professor at the Yale Child Study Center
and former deputy executive director of
UNICEF today we'll talk with Professor
Saleh about her recently published book
pathways to peace the transformative
power of women and children that she
worked on in collaboration with dr.
James Lachman and Catherine Panzer brick
from Yale University
welcome professor Saleh thank you very
much it's a great pleasure to be with
you thank you so afternoon
let's begin with an overview of the book
tell us about it okay the book is
pathways to peace the transformative
power of families and children and it
all started in 2013 when Ernest Rickman
which is a forum in Germany convened a
meeting to review a very important
premise do the way we're a the ways we
raise our children have an impact on
peace or help to promote peace also
another question can peaceful childhood
create a culture of peace and as you
know there is more and more evidence
that the how we invest in the early
years of the child can have an impact in
creating a culture of peace and we
thought by presenting this book we can
put our hands with the international
community and contribute to the debate
on peace building creating a culture of
peace and particularly justice and peace
in society it also started with the
journey of mr. Lachman and professor
Lachman who went to Turkey and met with
an organization a non-governmental
organization mother-child foundation
and they had programs in early childhood
development development in all the
country in Turkey in villages in cities
in and within communities and they so
they realized that early childhood
development the programs had an impact
in creating peace at home in the
community and at large so they asked
professor Blackman they wanted the
scientific evidence and it all started
from there also it started with the
launch of a consortium on early
childhood development that we launched
at UNICEF in 2012 and also to join the
forces of the international community to
find answers and ways to really build a
peaceful society but not only peaceful
inclusive and that is why it is
important so we thought we will bring
you know the evidence of knowledge the
evidence and inform that debate and it
was very timely why is it timely because
of the situation in the world millions
and millions of children are living in
environments of violence and in the book
it categorizes violence in two ways we
have the direct violence like when
children have you know abuse and all the
war the direct impact of war but also
there is the structural violence which
is very important which is the poverty
which is marginalization which is
oppression and also rights and
children's rights that are not conformed
to the Convention on the Rights of the
Child so we thought that we that our
contribution will help millions and
millions of children okay now there are
a number of contributors to the book so
you've you've collected research from a
number of people can you tell us who are
some of the contributors and what were
some of their findings we had more than
40 contributors and they came from all
Sciences so it is multi
disciplinary and that is the strength
and the power of it and so we had for
example anthropologists sociologists
biologists neurobiologist and also
people from peacebuilding and also from
religious studies so it was so important
that they had to answer questions for
example does human biological
development impact peace and this is
something new this is groundbreaking
science that is very important and does
it yes does it does because the some of
the findings say that when children are
exposed to violence is detrimental to
their development they will not develop
to their full potential and also it
affects the brain how important the
brain development in the early years of
life and then all their experience in
the first year even of life will
determine the capacity of the brains for
life and also how important is to build
a good brain you have to have good care
child caring you have to have also in
like involve parents in so that they in
they put cognitive and emotional and all
these aspects of them are very important
but also health and nutrition so it is a
holistic approach but the most important
thing is safety and protection how to
create loving environment how to create
environments that care for children and
particularly in times of war and
conflict or where children are refugees
and n displaced and also how important
is for example bonding and this is very
important and the role of parents and
good parenting because as I said this
will you know have an great impact on
the brain and can be transmitted across
generations and this is what we say the
study of epigenetics which is also
groundbreaking
so and so in this we know that good
early childhood care positive parenting
has a great impact on children and
particularly under future life and this
was through research that was done by
the contributors yes by the contributors
and we had the other research for
example other contribution to the book
what are the good interventions what are
so they showcased interventions from
United States to Nigeria to South Africa
to Lebanon to Turkey that show how can
good interventions also create an
environment of peace
can you speak to some of the specific
interventions that were done yes sure
for example I spoke about a little bit
the interventions in Turkey but also
interventions for example in Lebanon
where we work with mothers in
Palestinian refugee camps and as you see
as you know the environment in a camp
are not always positive so working with
mothers had a great impact on the
relationship with their children and not
only with the relationship with the
children but also the centre's had an
impact in creating cohesion in the
community okay so when you say it's
important from you know mothers to work
with their children or what specifically
was being done with the women in the
camps to foster that yeah for example
they followed a few weeks of training
and talking and and working with them
how to deal with the child how when
their child is violent what should they
do do they spank their children or not
sometimes you spank children so they
learn that this is not the the best way
how to listen to their children so all
this has really a great impact as I said
in the family but also in a community
that is not very positive right and also
in South Africa for example because
this will help when they mothers meet
when parents meet the role of the father
is very important when they meet in the
centers they transcend the divide of
religious divide ethnic divide because
they become mothers together and fathers
together to take care of their children
right so the last chapter of the book
talks about effective policies and
programs that can alleviate violence and
promote peace
can you talk in specifics about some of
them yes that the the most important
thing is how to transmit the science
because if we want science and keep it
in the libraries if not it is not
important it's how you transmit it how
can communities how can government's how
can the United Nations
you know benefit from this so we have to
transmit it so if so that we have
policies so that governments also for
example realize that early childhood
development are important and they
should be owned by the countries should
be owned by the by the government they
should put budgets for you know for them
because sometimes they think especially
if countries are poorer they will try to
put budgets for other things but not for
early childhood development but I think
sharing this information and in this
chapter we have recommendations at all
levels recommendation for governments
for example we have recommendations for
the United Nations and so member states
of the United Nations who are working on
peace and security have to know that
early childhood development should be
part of all the peace building programs
and on the community level it's very
important that for example mayors and
local governments for example we have
examples of mayors for children or
mayor's for the rights of children in
Italy in Japan and in other places how
can we have mayors for peace how can
we have mayor's for early childhood
development so what we are doing and
what is the most important goal for us
is to have a resolution at the United
Nations a resolution that states that
families and children are important
agents of change and important agents of
peace so the resolution we are working
on it to be adopted next year then it
can because a resolution at the United
Nations can mobilize all member states
193 member states but also the role of
nongovernmental organizations is very
important because sometimes when non
governments cannot do cannot implement
everything you know civil society is
important to help and we have examples
of programs in many countries that are
led by nongovernmental organizations but
most importantly how to share this
knowledge and the translator of this
knowledge is very important how to give
the router guide communities how to
guide governments it's very important
and also very important in respecting
cultures I was going to ask you altars
must play a large role here from country
to country and it's I think they're
important to recognize that in terms of
trying to implement yes for instance can
you have you any experience with can you
cite any specific examples of how
culture will come into play in any
particular for example even if I go back
to the culture in Lebanon I mean the
culture is very important because you
cannot tell mothers that all what they
were doing is wrong so you have to bring
it in a way to guide them in the new way
in the and to translate this
groundbreaking science to them in a
language that they understand and that
is not against for example their culture
and their and their traditions of course
there are sometimes harmful traditional
practices that little by little stir
by step as also with my work in UNICEF
we did so step by step you can guide
them to get rid of those traditions for
example of spanking a child or for all
these traditions so it's important and
we have a whole chapter that talks about
culture and also we have a chapter where
you have also involvement as I said from
religious inter-religious dialogue
because in a community you have
everybody and you have to involve
everybody you're having to involve the
leaders the local governments you have
traditional Chiefs religious leaders
civil society itself and mother fathers
and the older caregivers the teachers
for example the pediatricians in there
in that community so how to join forces
together to bring peace through the
transformative power of early childhood
development right so if there is one
thing that you would like readers to
take from the book what would it be that
families and children are not only
victims in times of war and conflicts
are not only victims to violence but are
agents of change through the
transformative power of early childhood
development thank you so much for being
here with us thank your worth thank you
it's a great pleasure and just to say
that it was a great pleasure and honor
to work with the two other professors
professor Lachman James Lachman and
Catherine Panther Brick who are also
known for their science but for example
professor panther break for her work on
resilience and we have a lot in our book
on really resilience how to build
resilience of communities and and
families especially in times of conflict
and of course all the work of professor
Lichtman on childhood very good thank
you so much thank you thank you for more
information about Professor Salah and
her research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale.edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
McMillon Center for International and
area studies at Yale